when I started to obsess about music I
was really I was pretty young I found
some Beatles records and and but I think
my next love was Cat Stevens like after
the Beatles I got to induct him into the
the writers songwriters Hall of Fame and
I was I was losing my mind well you
asked by Cat Stevens to induct him into
the writer's Hall of Fame I'd like to
think so I have no idea but uh but
really but I I don't know you know may
you know that would be really nice but
he was so nice to me and then I gave him
such a my introduction I worked really
hard at my introduction so that when
when he came up he's like what am I
supposed to say but which was nice of
him but uh he's you know he repeated a
lot of what I said to him
when you're singing uh Father and Son
one of my favorite songs and I would
imagine that had special meaning to you
because your father you lost your father
when you were 10 years old yeah so um it
was a really powerful song because it
also is about the conflict between
a father and a son you know so which is
normal right uh but but I didn't have
that so I don't know why it
grab me as well because that was the
first song
um I haven't played in a long time but
that was the first song that I ever
learned how to play
um it's not time this is you you're
playing
take it easy take it easy
[Music]
there's so much you have to yeah and Cat
Stevens is watching you play this yeah
yeah that was that was yeah
am I going too fast there's the one
little burning who didn't licked it I
was trying to play and then the the
guitar players said he he just he's
drums the chords and the other guy plays
that I said Thank God even after all the
years of playing in front of thousands
of people when you see Cat Stevens
standing there now you're nervous right
because you're playing nice in front of
them yeah right I had this is a good
part
[Music]
you didn't want to sing over here you
wouldn't want to talk over yourself
this is me really good wait this is when
I get really amazing
[Music]
you love this guy AI he's one of the
reasons you're a musician and then
you're standing there and you're singing
his song in front of him It's gotta be
surreal yeah that so that you know I
that's the weird thing about managing to
you know you know work hard but also
kind of fall down the stairs or you know
be a pinball in the world and end up
you know where I am and where I get to
meet all these crazy like I you know
meet Cat Stevens like
I would I would my my ten-year-old 11
year old self would not would have been
impossible is that like beyond my most
insane dreams you know how many times I
wore out like Neil Young's
um your albums and at home how many
times like those records that I just and
then these
on a bench with them and talking about
whatever life it's just insane to me
when you did this you did this in front
of Neil Young
you did Needle and the Damage Done my
favorite Neil Young song
[Music]
that's another great guitar player Neil
Young
the first time I saw Neil
was at Farm Aid live
right and
he got in front of like
for me it was like
10 100 000 people
right just by himself on a chair and he
that's all he needs blew the place he
blew the place apart
what an artist and I was like Wow bad
guys who can do that after you perform
that does Neil come up to you and say
Well done or hey I like the way you did
my song or is it
I don't we maybe we talked about it
afterwards he but he I think we one time
I played it for him in any at um and he
said you know thanks man
um but but thanks man you know I
surprised him he's uh I love to share
the stage with Neil but
um if if there was a fight in a bar
I'd like to be on Neil Sykes I think he
I think he could definitely throw a
punch too but he doesn't sound like he
could throw a punch necessarily but well
he does something yeah but I think I
feel like he's a he's a brawler he's a
baller yeah no yeah it doesn't take [__]
from anything no I don't think he's
gonna take [__] from anybody and I think
it doesn't matter you know he'd kick the
bar stool back and be like that said I'm
gonna [__] you up now I think you have
fantasies when you play Needle into
damage you're done in front of Neil
Young do you ever have fantasies like
he's going to come up there afterwards
and say you know I usually don't like
people's interpretations of my songs but
like you're wanting
no thank God no I want I just want I
just want him not to go you suck
um you know you know
he could he could he that he would have
the power in his hand
um to say to destroy me for the rest of
my life he said that I did a Paul Simon
song in front of Paul Simon I couldn't
even look at him what did you do what
song
you could call me Al
no did you that's the one you chose yeah
I'm shocked and there is so many words
in that song
I didn't you they said would you do that
you know and so I said okay but I said
that said that before I went back and
listened to the record
recording yeah I mean they see holy Lord
there's not enough lung in a human lung
in a human to get all those words in but
I got them in but that's why I think
your Brave like I would not want I'm not
a recording artist but I do not want to
do you could call me out I would want to
do old friends you would have been great
do you know this song all friends I
would have loved to do that one there
was maybe a couple that I would have
liked to do but then the thing is then
they said but won't you do call You Can
Call Me Al and I was like okay
and then I did that I'm really glad I
did it but I got to tell you the band
was killing they had a band there that
was they were murdering so they covered
a lot of space for me and I watched that
tribute I mean Paul's sitting right
there in the front row did not even
glance down I knew exactly where it was
I looked everywhere but at him I was
like hell no because if I'd looked at
him and he was like
ah [__] I just I had to [__] the bed
foreign